[Music]
flying back r3 what they were calling
hostages we call them fine people we
really find people seem to be healthy
I'll be there to greet them Mike will be
with me it will be I think a very
special time nobody thought this was
going to happen and if it did it would
be years or decades frankly nobody
thought this was going to happen and I
appreciate kim jeong-hoon doing this
what happens who knows we have a chance
at something really great for the world
and great for North Korea and great for
everyone
president Trump in the Cabinet Room with
a big announcement that he had tweeted
earlier letting the world know that
there was a success coming I'm pleased
to inform you the Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo is in the air on his way
back from North Korea with three
wonderful gentlemen that everyone is
looking so forward to meeting they seem
to be in good health also good meeting
with Kim jong-un date and place set
going on to say that he secretary Pompeo
and his guests will be landing at
Andrews Air Force Base at 2:00 a.m. the
morning I'll be there to greet them very
exciting you heard about this and
they're the three coming back to America
the date and time said we're getting
word that it looks like Singapore is the
place that this will happen and likely
the first week or a few days in June for
this meeting between President Trump and
Kim jong-nam we'll start there with the
panel let's bring the men Charles hurt
opinion editor for The Washington Times
Charles Lane an opinion writer for The
Washington Post and Jason Riley Wall
Street Journal columnist and senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute Jason
obviously a significant moment that sets
the table for what the president hopes
will be another significant moment yes
it was a clearly a diplomatic victory
for the president he deserves a lot of
credit here clearly this was a point of
contention between North Korea and the
u.s. these hostages and you know it's a
good-faith gesture by North Korea that
they came came through with it but I
stressing that we've been here before
we've had hostage releases in the run-up
to summits we've had Kim
kay is promising peace before we've said
this what we've seen recently is a charm
offensive by North Korea and I and I
hope that the president understands that
he needs to keep his eye on the ball
here he's repeatedly said I'm gonna get
a good deal or no deal at all and I
think we have to remember that that that
North Korea and its leader has not
suddenly turned into some statesman who
loves peace and wants nothing else to do
with his past pursuit of nuclear weapons
and that's what's important here you see
the pictures of Mike Pompeo the
Secretary of State on the ground in
North Korea a 90 minute meeting with Kim
jong-un clearly they're hearing
something from the North Koreans that is
encouraging to them setting the table
for this summit you know what strikes me
about this is you could almost say that
President Trump is approaching North
Korea the way President Obama approached
Iran with sort of a great deal of Hope
in the power of a new departure by the
United States with an old enemy who is
building nuclear weapons of course there
are a lot of differences one is that
North Korea actually has nuclear weapons
Iran had not acquired them yet and I
think very a real wild card here is that
Kim jong-un is young he's only thirty
years old or thirty two years old and
it's just possible that he is looking
for some kind of agreement that will
guarantee him personally and his family
a hold on power that not just the regime
but him personally would be guaranteed
in power and that may be something that
gives the United States a little bit of
leverage in the sense that he unlike the
previous his father and grandfather was
not sort of at the end of his career but
at the very beginning of one be very
interesting to see how this works out
but I have to say I do agree with Jason
that this is so far nothing that we
haven't in some form or another already
saying it was yeah relief from the
sanctions he wants more aid from the
West he wants what the country is always
wanted so the president just in the past
one minute tweeting out looking forward
to greeting the hostages
parentheses no longer at 2:00 a.m. so
the president will will be there at
Andrews and I'm sure we'll have a an
image of that you think there might be a
picture taken and some videos that yeah
it is amazing the flair for theatrics
that this president has and I think that
not only I think that that's it's a good
thing for a president to have that sort
of understanding but I also think it's
probably a very smart way to deal with
with foreign enemies of course the
terrible thing about the Iran deal was
that was that it was so front loaded
with both you know he you know bundles
pallets of cash and then real money and
sanctions relief it was all front-loaded
and all of the the tough stuff came
later and you know we can all debate
about whether or not that stuff is
working or not but but that but you know
to be sure as Donald Trump approaches
this I don't think that he is going to
front-load
things and I think and it would be
terrible if he did front-load all the
the goodies at the beginning and then
had the tough stuff later you're gonna
have I mean you don't have to entice
them somehow yeah absolutely how the
last night Korea deal was structured it
was but I also think that you know a lot
of the experts now are saying that Oh
pulling out of the Iran deal is going to
undermine the North Korea deal I kind of
see that as a little bit a little bit
differently I think that it it it shows
that Donald Trump is willing to sort of
stick to what he believes which is an
important thing but it also means I hope
it means that what Donald Trump one ends
up doing is gets an actual treaty that
Congress that's where to that point I
want to read this because I just felt it
was interesting National Review
President Obama had the chance to make a
true American promise by submitting the
Iran deal as a treaty but he knew that
America wouldn't make that deal he knew
that most of the Senate including a
number of Democrats were opposed to the
deal the Iran deal did not represent
America's word it represented Obama's
word under the American system one
president's pledge does not bond the
next president there was a
constitutional process for securing
enduring international obligations in
other words if a president wants to
preserve his policies he should follow
constitutional processes Donald Trump
didn't break an American promise he
corrected an American mistake I think it
was interesting well-written
and the pushback - you know the the
criticism that Susan Rice's and the John
Kerry's and the President himself former
President himself Obama complaining
about this President Obama neither
sought nor received permission from
Congress or approval from Congress to do
this and which pave the way for the way
Trump was able to roll it back as far as
the geopolitical yeah you know where it
is that that's the that was that was the
the initial sin hear that because that
is not how you go about dealing with
foreign powers when it comes to cutting
deals you don't go it alone you go
through Congress which of course has to
answer to the American public so he had
neither congressional support nor really
the popular support of American people
on the flip side Chuck there's still the
question of what is next with when it
comes to the Iran deal and you know
renegotiating in this 100-day 880 day
period is it Iran joins the long list of
people in this world who did something
very important never dreaming that
Donald Trump would ever become president
of the United States they made a
calculation that the United States had
made a strategic turn in its approach to
the Middle East that they were now going
to sort of like Nixon to China they were
gonna open to Iran and that this would
continue in a bipartisan basis or
perhaps Hillary Clinton would be elected
and then BOOM we have an election and
not and then BOOM number two is the
president actually keeps his promise
this is very disruptive inside Iran
notwithstanding whatever bluster they
may be putting out they have been thrown
back on their heels and they're looking
for a strategy and very quickly in
Europe is gonna have to decide whether
they want to deal with Iran for deal
with the u.s. very quickly is there a
risk here that like President Obama who
desperately wanted that Iran deal for
legacy issues and the administration was
clearly focused on that like a laser
that President Trump is in the same
position with North Korea touting it
before he sits down with Kim Jong
there's always a risk of that but we do
you're talking about a completely
different guy you're talking about a guy
who you know obviously prides himself on
being a very smart deal maker but but
but you know this is you know he has at
every turn underscored the fact that it
may or may not work out and I hate
walk away yeah get up to walk